I see these edge cases, like we say,
look, if it's legal it can be there,
but we still see edge cases
where we have to make decisions.
So what's like an edge case?
I mean,
let's see, I mean there is,
I don't even want to go here,
but I will all right there,
there is a type of animation,
oh porn anomia yeah, yeah.
That is very sketchy.
That Uber, you know like child
porn, animated child porn,
and we've taken the stance that look,
it's, it could fall under obscenity laws,
so we don't, we're not cool. But you
know, that is a huge debate, right?
That, that that has not been decided
by the Supreme Court if animated,
you know,
kids like they will do the weirdest stuff.
And I,
I just don't want to be telling people
what is and what is not art. Right.
So like some of that Japanese
stuff with tentacles, look,
some of that stuff was just like,
what is happening here?
Like octopuses banging chicks and every
hole and they're choking on it and
they've got one of their ass and one
of their vagina and it's all like very,
very liquidity. You know, there's a lot
of splattering going on. You're like,
what the fuck is this? And is that okay?
Because it's just art, right? I mean,
if it was a person getting fucked left,
right and center by an octopus,
he'd be like, yeah, I think we've crossed
some lines here. That's beastiality.
But if it's an image and then,
then the image is a girl with
a school girl costume on,
she's dressed like a Catholic school girl,
a little skirt,
and she's getting banged by an octopus.
What do you do with that?
Right? I, yeah. Yeah. What would
you do? It's a good question.
I'm glad I don't have a social media
site where I have to make the decision.
Well,
the real concern would be,
is this something that is actually
illegal? That's the thing, right? And we,
we've tried to look at the case law and
we've seen that this type of stuff has
been, you know, called obscenity before.
And so we're just not going to
risk it. But I, I still, you know,
in a alright, nipples, nipples look right.
Did you know that free the nipple
started out with fortune? Well,
everywhere. It's a whole, it's a
whole movement. To be honest, it,
Time magazine just did a really
interesting piece about a,
a statue they got banned from Facebook in
a sense. He was a naked ancient statue.
That's a nipple. Like,
I'm sorry, that's not,
that's not realistic.
That that's not helping society
taking down a naked statue.
When we were talking about the other day,
uh,
during the Superbowl that a Adam Levine
had his shirt off and Brian read,
Ben was like, Hey, d wasn't that like what
Janet Jackson got in trouble for? Like,
yeah,
why does,
why is it okay if Adam Levine shows his
nipples and Janet Jackson's nipples are
offensive because there's
sexualized because she's a woman.
This is the weird fact.
Men had to gain the right to have their
nipples shown in public back in the day.
When's the day I, if you, if you go
on the, the free the nipple site,
go on their Instagram or something.
I think that's maybe where I saw it back
when I used Instagram. But you know,
society is evolving.
We're going to get there,
we're going to be able to handle it I
think or give people the controls so that
they can only see the types of
things that they want to see.
That's ultimately what it's about.
So like you should have like a filter.
Do I want 18 plus? Do our want. Um, PG 13.
Like what, what kind of distinction
do I want? Yeah, yeah. And then when,
when things come up,
like one of the things that Instagram
has been doing is like they say,
I follow a lot of hunters and Instagram
has things where they say, warning,
this is a sensitive content.
Uh,
nature is metal gets popped on that
a lot too because nature's metals and
Instagram site,
that's all like these crazy images and
videos of animals eating other animals
and attacking their animals.
And sometimes some of them,
they just decided this one's too fucked
up. You know, like just decide you,
I like this one of them where
a a lion is a looking out of a,
a Willdabeast asshole. Like
from the inside, like this,
this giant hole they've eaten through
its stomach and the, it's looking out,
it's asshole. And then I'm like, yeah,
this one you're going to have to click
on your own. You have to double click.
What do you got Jamie? Basically
from, I just looked up,
Tarzan is the catalyst for why guys
wanted to wear their shirts off.
They had like a 1920s 19 terrorists
they had to wear and pools.
They had to wear a top.
But look,
this only covers one [inaudible] they're
probably tired or sweaty or alien right
there. That's how they started doing
down the strap. Look at it says here,
saucy lifeguards, flash,
rebellious nipples.
Ah,
areas 37 that's hilarious.
So it was Tarzan 1937 in New
York state's male shirtless ban.
That's when they overturned at the
incident attracted press attention as
Atlantic city. The other waterfronts
similarly mandated against men. Nips.
Would that legal domino tipped along
with the help of Hollywood hunks.
And you were talking about how
their Twitter has porn. Yes. Yo,
a lot banned from Google play for that.
Twitter has it.
They're up on Google play. It's Twitter
has a substantial amount of porn.
You know, you follow like some of them
gals and they just want you to see, look,
here's one in the my pussy right
there. Take a look. Thank full blown.
Not Offensive. Well, it's not
offensive. You've, you've followed them.
If you follow certain porn stars, we
can't make their own terms. Oh really?
But they're just allowing it because
they know they want that traffic. Oh,
is that what it is? They want
that traffic to traffic, bro.
Yeah. Um, it's a problem if you hand
your phone to your kid, you know,
and they accidentally click on
that link and I'm like, Mommy,
what's happening with her?